it's great to welcome to the program
today Travis reader who is a faculty
member at the johns hopkins berman
institute of bioethics and also author
of the book in pain a bioethicists
personal struggle with opioids Travis so
great to talk to you today thanks for
having me on David really appreciate
this
so maybe just to get started so so the
audience can understand your personal
background in the connection to opioids
talk to us generally about the
motorcycle accident you were in the
surgeries and sort of the path into
opioids yeah it was it was not a great
year 2015 I went out for a motorcycle
ride on Memorial Day weekend and I
didn't make it three blocks from home
before a van sight sorry before a van
t-boned me and crushed my foot between
the bumper and the motorcycle so the
injury that resulted was really severe I
was in what's called a limb Salvage
situation so that meant that my foot was
at threat of amputation and the severity
of that sort of injury me means that I
had a lot of surgeries to look forward
to I was gonna be hospitalized for weeks
or months and so the result of that is
that I was on a lot of pain medication
for quite a long time and thanks to the
tolerance that opioids built up I was on
escalating doses of pain medication for
about two months total and before that
in your life had you been on opiate
painkillers not that I can recall you
know maybe at some point when I was
younger I had a nasty broken bone from
sports and got vicodin and probably
wasn't even given it by my parents I was
considered opiate naive by the physician
so I'd certainly not been on the pills
for three or six months prior and maybe
had never been and when you were put on
the drugs was that one particular drug
the entire time or were they were there
different ones lots of different ones so
for this sort of accident I was a trauma
case you know you tend to get passed
through systems and so on the ambulance
I get intravenous morphine when I got to
the hospital they switched that to
fentanyl and eventually my IV drug
choice not mine but if the hospitals was
hydromorphone brand-name dilaudid but
then to kind of build up something that
I could take home because IV medicine is
not something you typically can take
home I was put on oxycodone and that
comes in both the immediate release form
so just normal actually codon that goes
in your system as quick as the oral
medicines can and then extended-release
oxycodone which most people know under
the brand name oxycontin
so at what point in this or is there a
point or how early is there a discussion
about there a risk with these drugs you
need to be careful we need to be careful
or did that not come up until you
realize that there was a problem yeah it
never came up I mean this is probably
the most shocking feature of my entire
story is you know I had this two-month
period where I was on high and
escalating doses of opioids and I was in
three different world class hospitals on
the eastern seaboard I had you know 10
12 maybe more clinicians who signed
their name to a prescription for these
medications I was seen by dozens of
doctors and nurses coming through and
not a single person ever said anything
to me about the formation of dependence
which means that you know all withdrawal
if I'm taken if the medication is taken
away nobody talked about the risk of
addiction the only cost of these
medications that was ever raised was
constipation everybody was very worried
about constipation but that was it and
what about as you talked about as you
develop a tolerance your on escalating
you know amounts of the active
ingredients even at that point there was
not a discussion about okay these doses
are starting to get quite high now no
and as a matter of fact the only real
advice I got about pain regarding
medication was you have to stay ahead of
the pain a couple times early on I got
behind the pain they say and it's just
excruciating you really feel like you're
going to die sometimes you hope you're
going to die the pain is just
all-consuming and so they say look don't
risk getting behind the pain make sure
you take the medication before you're in
that situation and so you know I thought
I was being a good soldier I was
following doctor's orders in every four
hours you know I popped the next
oxycodone pill every 12 hours I popped
the next oxycontin pill if I felt it
wearing off even a little bit I'd call
the prescribing doc say hey my tolerance
is going up and he'd say okay let's pump
it from 15 to 20 milligrams or whatever
so at what point did you realize that
you were starting to have a problem I
never did I went to a trauma surgeon
follow-up appointment and so he's a guy
I hadn't seen and weeks he you know
initially pulled the bones and my foot
back together and then passed me off to
other teams to fix the rest of the foot
and he's just kind of going through his
checklist and sees the doses I'm on and
gets very stern very concerned as as you
know these doses are far too high you're
two months out you've got to get off the
meds now but he didn't offer any advice
you know it's kind of like you've got to
get off but that's not my problem
I haven't been controlling this train so
he sent me to the plastic surgeon who
had been writing the most recent
prescriptions and what did what happened
at that point well the plastic surgeon
was much less concerned and he also just
clearly didn't know what he was doing
you know he would admit that much later
to me he would apologize but he just
hadn't dealt with dependence before and
so he was like oh yeah you have to taper
the pills so let's divide your daily
dose into four drop a quarter each week
and you'll be off the medication in a
month and did that I mean when you were
told that number one did you understand
like the importance and urgency of it
and number two was that was that
practical advice that you could actually
follow so I think my partner saw dia I
think she was skeptical you she's a
research scientist by training and she
asked some follow-up questions I didn't
know anything you know I was still
fairly traumatized and out of it so I
was like yeah you know this is the plan
but no it's it's terrible advice so what
I would find out much much later turns
out more than a year later in my own
research is that you practically never
should start tapering a dependent
patient at faster than a 10 percent dose
reduction per week and then some
patients will be able to go faster if
they haven't been on for very long and
some patients will need to go much much
because the withdrawal will be so severe
and in my case that withdrawal was very
severe and so as soon as I dropped that
first dose these medications have a
really short half-life so on the first
day that you drop a significant dose if
you're a dependent you'll feel
withdrawal and it's it's excruciating
was there a point at which you did not
need the doses you were on for the
amount of pain you were experiencing but
started to recognize that there were
other reasons why you were inclined to
take the medication that's a really good
and really hard question you know it
kind of requires me to be a mind reader
of my distant past self yeah I kind of
feel like the answer must be yes I was
so concerned to stay ahead of the pain
and I was scared of what I had
experienced in the past and so I did a
lot of clock watching I did a lot of you
know early medicating I was not chasing
euphoria that was not something that
happened to me at least not yet and so I
don't think I was you know kind of as
far down the path towards addictive
behavior as as you can certainly get but
I was I was almost certainly medicating
more than I should have and more than I
needed to and so what I knew only much
much later and what I know now is that
very few people should be on that high a
dose for that long because the opioids
are going to cause profound dependence
that's just the way they work and they
tend to not work very well as analgesics
as pain medication in the long term and
so likely what I should have done is
starting in the first couple weeks out
of the hospital I should have been as
aggressively as possible titrating down
the dose and putting up with the most
pain possible and I was just in no place
to do that no one no one told me that so
how bad like what would you say was the
peak of the problem ultimately in terms
of dependence and then what did actually
ultimately work to start reducing the
doses properly yeah so the sick joke
opioid tapering is that it gets worse
the farther along you get because if
dropping by asset reduction each week or
each two weeks then the more you drop
the higher percentage dose reduction
that is yes and of complicated right but
yeah first week it was only a quarter
the second week it was a third the third
week it was half and then the fourth
week you dropped all the rest right and
so the severity of withdrawal is
relative to that percentage dose
reduction and so every we'd got workers
and it was in the fourth week that you
know I hadn't slept well and weeks and I
hadn't slept at all in days because
withdrawal is the opposite of the drug's
effects and so opiates to date you
withdraw keeps you kind of jittery and
hyper alert and and say I felt like I
had a kind of fire inside me and I was
incredibly depressed because the
opposite of euphoria which you get with
opioids is dysphoria and I cried all the
time and I thought I was profoundly
broken and in that fourth week I was I
was convinced from the inside that I was
gonna die from withdrawal and you could
not have convinced me otherwise I
thought that I had special access to
just help broke and I was and I was
pretty sure I wasn't going to survive it
and once you got to and passed that
fourth week what happened well so
basically you know the second part of
your question was what worked and
nothing worked I just I was incredibly
fortunate that I had a really strong
support system namely my partner Satya I
had a one and a half year old daughter
at home CNM and I tell a story about her
in the book where she kind of
unwittingly probably she's
one-and-a-half years old but she
comforts me in a particular moment where
where I'm at this cusp where I really
think I'm not gonna survive this and
what what haunts me for the months after
I finally make it out of this is I'm
quite sure that I would not have made it
out if I hadn't so desperately wanted to
be a good husband again to be a good
father to get this life back right and
so what happens to everybody else who
doesn't have that support system who
doesn't have a bunch of things in their
life that they're desperately looking
forward to it would have been so easy to
medic
get away the suffering especially
because doctors were telling me it was
okay to do that they're like oh we can't
offer you an advice just go back on the
pills if it's that bad yeah I think this
is what's often missing from the
understanding in people who have not
experienced this personally which is
it's very easy to just say I don't know
it just sounds like I could taper and
then switch to a bunch of advil and then
taper the advil and it just it's hard to
imagine when you rehear the stories that
don't go the way yours went but rather
it goes to you know by I couldn't get
the prescriptions buying the pills on
the street was too expensive so I ended
up with heroin it seems inconceivable to
people who have not actually ever had
this medication but the line between
your path and that path seems to be
relatively a small margin is what I'm
hearing from you it's razor-thin you
you're so so right like that's the
central insight here and whenever
anybody says to me you know you were so
strong congratulations I'm like wasn't
strong I was I was a complete but I
thought I was gonna die at every moment
I was dragged across the finish line by
my family and by the way at the end of
that story I did give up I refilled a
prescription because I couldn't take it
anymore and just by luck that was the
night I fell asleep without taking any
more pills and that that sleep kind of
pulled me back together enough though I
thought I can finish detoxing but I was
ready to go back and when I had said to
Sadia is if I go back on the meds
I will never come off then because I
will never be able to do this to myself
again and we both knew that we knew that
that was my commitment and that was my
belief and we decided to go back on with
them anyway so yeah like it sounds crazy
I'm a faculty member at Johns Hopkins I
have all of this kind of access and
privilege that not everybody has and I
can tell you right now if I gone back on
the pills which I was so close to doing
and then I'd been cut off I would have
been willing to buy them on the street
right boy that it's it's it's that
that's it that's an incredible thing
that I think a lot of people just don't
understand until they're in it and
that's why this is so pernicious and and
I don't know if you think it's gotten
this was 2015 I don't know how much you
know about
whether protocols have improved since
then but this clearly is still a major
problem it's a huge problem I work with
a lot of hospitals and healthcare
systems now and I speak at conferences
and advise organizations and what I can
say is that the best ones are at least
asking for this help and part of why I
wrote the book you know I want everyone
to read it I'm thrilled that you read it
I'd be thrilled if everybody who thinks
they might be a pain patient someday
which is all of us right reads it but
one of my great ambitions is I hope
every doctor feels like they need to
know this right and I don't think it's
gotten there yet I I know the
institutions the really good ones that
have resources that are putting them
towards this problem but I don't think
most places have figured this out yet
and there's still this deeply fractured
system or clinicians are totally
comfortable writing a prescription that
they do not have the knowledge or
willingness to then see through they
don't know how to taper patients off of
it they don't know how to manage it long
term and that's the problem yeah it's
it's it's stunning that that's the the
situation the book is fascinating it's
called in pain a bioethicists personal
struggle with opioids we've been
speaking with the book's author Travis
reader Travis really appreciate your
time today absolutely thanks for having
me David